so as cool as you might think my life is
i have a recurring nightmare that i've
had for
26 years
i'm somehow walking outside a stadium
a baseball stadium
and i can hear them announcing the
starting lineup to a baseball game
i'm not kidding you and i can hear the
music playing and they say
leading off in center field number eight
and i know it's me
i played center field here and i let off
right number eight eddie mylett and i
hear him yelling
but i can't get in the stadium
i'm like i'm supposed to be playing
right like i'm supposed to be and i
cannot get in the door like i'm running
around saying look i'm in my uniform i'm
i'm in i'm in they're like we don't know
who you are man i'm like no you need to
let me in i just they just announced me
i'm the starting center fielder man
they're like i'm sorry man we don't know
who you are you can't play
and then every single time i have a
dream i lap around the stadium
trying to get back in
to the game
except i can't get in
this is a true story i'm 47 years old i
had this dream last month i had it the
month before that i had it the month
before that okay
and then i wake up it's a nightmare
every time i'm in the dream i know i'm
having it but i can't get out of it
and the reason i have that dream is
because i miss playing so much
and the real reason i have the dream is
because when i was here listen to me
okay when i was here
i did not give it everything i had
over and over and over again you must be
working on how great you think you are
what you're worthy of what you deserve
because you get out the way you change
your identity
is this
you change your identity listen to me on
this remember this when i leave you
change your identity
because it's based on what you believe
you're worth
what you believe you deserve
we take it more seriously we have more
fun we're laughing our asses off but we
are out working everybody in the
conference everybody in the country we
hit the gym that way we stretch that way
you become a team nobody wants to play
now if you did that
you know what starts to happen to this
team
you start to believe you deserve stuff
you probably aren't good enough to get
you will literally win games you're not
supposed to win
this team outworks everybody in there at
bat they battle on every pitch when
they're in the back i want you to think
about that for a minute i mean what if
you didn't give away a single freaking
pitch all year batting now one dude you
grind every pitch you battle every pitch
what if someone would have told me this
when i was here
battle every pitch man
every pitch is a fight every pitch is a
battle it's you it's a team but it's you
and the dude with the wrong lid on on
the mound battle his ass wanna be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's evan carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
you've got more inside you you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven wealth habits
that you can adopt
enjoy
habit number two is win the money game
with jon aserath there are five things
that you need to get really good at if
you want to really win the game of money
one you have to get good
at earning more money
and every day
you have to invest a little bit of time
asking yourself this question and this
is again if you're really serious about
earning more money how am i going to
earn more money today
and let's say you have a job
let's say you have a job you say great
how am i going to earn money outside of
my job it has to be a focus because if
it's not a focus
then you're not going to do it so how am
i going to earn money today this week
this month
number one number two and these are the
five pillars of financial success number
two how am i going to manage my money
better
too many of you are spending too much
money every month
and you are not managing your money
and you're spending the future
instead of spending what you have or
less than what you have so you can
really start focusing on wealth building
okay
so
money management and creating budgets
and sticking to those budgets is
critical number three
investing
one of the things i taught both of my
sons when they were very very very young
when i gave them money
let's say i gave them one dollar
i gave them a dollar and here's how this
went 10 cents you have to give
to other people or causes that you like
10 cents i want you to save no matter
what
and then 50 cents you can spend and 30
cents
put in your bank just in case something
comes up that you want in the future 10
cents giveaway
all right 10 cents save in a never touch
account or invest in a never touch
account 50 you can spend so are you
living within your budget are you living
within your means are you investing
even a dollar a day
to get into the habit of being an
investor why because there's you working
for money and then there's money working
for you and if you develop the mindset
of being an investor
over time the law of compounding
interest
starts to work for you instead of you
working for it so you need to earn
manage invest fourth thing you need to
learn is how do i protect my assets
whether it's my business my home my
money how do i protect my assets that's
a skill you need to learn and then fifth
one
is all around
debt
now there's terrible debt like credit
card debt that you're paying 15 20 30
or 25 percent you know interest that's
compounded
okay and then there's debt that you can
get to invest and you get more money
from your investments than the debt
costs
so you can borrow money at two or three
or four percent or five percent and make
10 or 15 or 20 percent
and now you can make the spread so
that's using debt but there's also
getting out of debt
so there are two methods to get out of
debt one is to pay the credit card for
example with the highest interest rate
first and you knock it down
and the other way
is to pay a little bit off of each
credit card so you know that you're
making headway now psychologically it's
different for each person habit number
three be determined to win with les
brown i went to the next morning
necessary to start talking to people in
seeking and asking for what i wanted and
leveraging relationships and trying to
find out how do the people do it that
went ahead of me how do they do it and
then what is it i need to do how is it i
need to train myself to develop myself
what's the resources that will be
required in order to make it happen and
as i start seeking out and asking
questions i started running into people
said i know someone who can help you do
that and they help me get connected with
those people remember we have so much
energy that can take us so far it's
necessary that you hook up with some
other energy that can take you to the
next level i hooked up with them they
said let's let's go i said away we go
and guess what here we are
i love it you want your stuff it's
necessary you take responsibility for
that you make it happen that you don't
give up that you don't take any
objection or disappointment or defeats
personally that you keep on keeping on
that you don't decide that i can't make
it because you can't see the light at
the end of the tunnel that you realize
that's a part of the program and here's
something you've got to resolve say this
to yourself every day see as long as
you're breathing you've got a shot at
your dream that's the way i resolve say
this please
it's not over
until i win
you've got that right
it's not over until i win
not over till i get through
it's not over till i get over not over
till i get what i want y'all can't open
the day look out i'm gonna come back and
take the hinges off
that's how you got to do that
you've got to have that kind of courage
that type of determination if you want
to make it happen
it's you
that you've got to take personal
responsibility to make it happen that
you have got to to own what it is
that you want to do if it's taking care
of your well-being if it's making a
difference in our school system if it's
working with senior citizens if it's to
protect our ecology
if it's to create an economic
renaissance
if it's just to take yourself to another
level
it's you
you've got to make that happen we can
point out many things that can make it
inconvenient or can slow us down but
ultimately
it's on us
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there habit number four believe in
yourself with marissa peer doesn't
matter how talented you are if you don't
have self-belief
you're not going to get anywhere if you
have extraordinary self-belief very
little talent you can get everywhere but
if you have both if you have talent and
belief
it will actually make you unstoppable
and i work with a lot of football teams
a lot of football players and a lot of
those footballers come out of school at
14 they know they're going to be famous
players they don't really pursue an
education a lot of them have an
extraordinary negative self belief
because
they they're only good at sport which is
a great shame and one of my players at
the moment has now become a fantastic
commentator but i do a lot of work with
him to put in him
that belief because he wasn't great at
spelling and he wasn't great at school
because he knew he was going to be a
footballer
so
belief without talent will take you far
further than talent without belief but
if you have both you can go far but
everyone can learn self-belief habit
number five become financially literate
with robert kiyosaki i always ask people
what did you learn about money in school
and for the answer for most people is
nothing they want to learn economics
balance a checkbook but that's really
not
money
and the reason they don't learn about
money is because the story of rich dad
poor dad
is my poor dad it was a phd which stands
for poor helpless and desperate no he's
a good man but as you know they don't
learn much about money and my father
knew nothing about money
and that's the problem so we have all
these academic elites you know like
obama and hillary and those guys they
run the country with no financial
education
how about number six seek knowledge with
warren buffett what did you aspire to do
what did you aspire to become a very
wealthy person would you want to be
buying a stocks would you want to buy
companies what was your aspiration in
those early days i loved i love just
analyzing securities i just spent
hours and hours and hours just i kept
turning the pages of moody's which
instead of going you know you had no
internet then or anything else so you
had two sources of information moody's
and standard and poor's and and we
happened to have these sets of moodies
they were about in aggregate probably
about 8 000 pages
about five different manuals and
i went through those page by page
and well it must have been exciting oh
yeah
it's a little strange i mean you know i
i actually went to amazon
a few years ago and i found an old 1951
moody's now everybody else is going
there for playboy magazine but i'm
ordering the old booties uh you've got a
strange guy here
and habit number seven the last one
before some very special bonus clips is
try different things with kevin systrom
we live in a really special place where
people get to work on ideas where
failure is tolerated i mean if you
travel overseas to other places there's
a reason why silicon valley is so
different and it's because failure is
tolerated um you asked me a question
which is why did i end up getting it up
into the startup world
um i grew up in outside of boston
massachusetts in a small town very few
people have heard of called holliston
and it was there that i realized that i
loved doing lots of different stuff it's
not that i loved technology it was that
i loved doing lots of different stuff so
i went to boarding school and i was the
guy hanging a uh an antenna outside of
my dorm room window to do a pirate radio
station right like i i was designing
flyers for dances i was djing like i
just love doing a lot of different
things and when i read um
required reading in school our junior
year was this book called the new new
thing um kind of the netscape saga right
i read that and i said to myself like
this feels like an area of the world i
can come to
and be myself and do lots of different
things and see what sticks um so i was
drawn i i did a trip to stanford just to
see
the school because i was interviewing at
a bunch of east coast schools i came to
stanford and i was like there are palm
trees it's beautiful
and everyone loves working hard on
really cool stuff
and i remember it was one of those first
beautiful days back in massachusetts
like you know you go through the entire
winter and it's gray for those of you
from massachusetts you know what i'm
talking about and you get to the first
beautiful day and i was touring a
specific school i won't name my name and
there was like not a single person
outside
i just said to myself like i want to be
in a place where people want to enjoy
life but work hard too so stanford was
just like a natural event that's what
drew me to being out here and being kind
of um a little schizophrenic in how i
treat different ideas and go from thing
to thing
but that's kind of the ethos of an
entrepreneur
i feel like what i do matters
and i think i think that's really really
important i think people are starting
the business only trying to make money
often burn out and and don't make money
i've been doing youtube for
12 years now we've done over 10 000
videos not all of them are public and
people ask me well how do you keep going
like how do you not burn out how do you
stay consistent we haven't missed a day
of uploading a video in maybe 70 years
something like that something crazy
how because
i love what i'm doing because i feel
like it matters because this isn't it
look at this interview here with michael
is this work this doesn't feel like work
for me
this is fun
this is a holiday in canada for me right
now this is our independence day right
now we're filming this on canada
independence day right now and i'm here
talking with michael because it's fun
right and so when you're doing work that
you love and you feel is having an
impact
it's a lot easier to stay positive and
excited and have momentum where if
you're forcing yourself to do something
that you hate because you think it's
going to make you money that's when you
start diving on the path of boredom
and maybe ultimately depression the most
amazing thing
in your life
for most people in the normal
state of consciousness
and normal means
somewhat
or very insane
in the normal state of consciousness the
present moment is usually overlooked
habitually
unconsciously
people have been conditioned
to overlook
the most important thing
there ever is because
your entire life
consists of
the present moment
there never has been
anything else everything happened in the
present moment and when you remember it
it's the present moment
and when you think about the future
which of course never arrives as the
future
it can only arrive as the present moment
but people live as if the present moment
were
undesirable
or an obstacle or they actively dislike
it and some people habitually live
actively disliking the is-ness of the
present moment usually when you talk
about them now then people
it's usually associated with
okay the first thing that
appears then in your awareness perhaps
is
your surroundings
and that's already a great step
into the now it's the first important
step into the now
to become aware
of whatever surrounds you the space that
surrounds you wherever you may be and
whatever
takes place in that space
and you may notice when you become aware
of those sense perceptions because it's
through sense perceptions that you
become aware of whatever
happens around you
that involves visual auditory and such
to some extent the other senses too
the main ones being
visual and
seeing and hearing
so as we enter the now we become more
aware
of our
surroundings it's the first
step into the now
and now when you do that and let's do
that now just not as not thinking i'm
going to practice now not just becoming
more aware of your surroundings no
practice
and it's not a doing it's just
an awareness arises of the this room
the people in this room the man sitting
on the chair talking the lights
beautiful arrangement there
and that is
the space of now so you can so what the
word to use is you acknowledge what is
and close to acknowledging you go a
little bit deeper
you appreciate
what is
what before
you probably overlooked completely
and
that's already a wonderful thing and
there are some people
who are not yet ready to go any deeper
than that and that's fine
it's enough to just go two steps into
the now well let's let's call it three
people like the idea of steps
let's call it step one you become more
aware of your surroundings
step two
you acknowledge
oh
and with the acknowledgement comes a
sense of the goodness of the ways in
which life manifests continuously around
you there is an aliveness in everything
even in the middle of a city you might
say oh i prefer the forest or the beach
or the mountains
but even in the middle of the city
whatever happens all the movements in
the middle of a city
are manifestations of life life
manifesting as human beings running
around as cars as houses buildings and
noise and so on and there's also
something there that is fine
it's your
an acknowledgement of
life
and then comes an appreciation oh
you you might see something that you
before had not appreciated the sky for
example
how many times are you aware of the sky
and say oh
and it's beautiful
and even a cloudy sky there's always
this light filtering through the clouds
now you might notice when you become
aware of the
what i call the surface of now which are
the sensory perceptions that reveal the
world to you
[Music]
already a shift in consciousness happens
because now
you're not thinking as much
you cannot be very much aware of sense
perception and really be looking at the
sky or at a tree or a flower or a street
scene
and be thinking a lot you have to be
really there as the presence
for example now
so you simply acknowledge
the totality of this room
and that's beautiful
and then
you go a little deeper still
the next step
takes you deeper then you can ask
yourself
what else is there to them now apart
from the things that arise in my sense
perception what else is there say
anything else is that what the now is
what appears in the now
no
it's what appears in the now but it's
not yet to the now
so to become aware of the present moment
to become aware of sense perceptions is
an important step and some people are so
out of touch with their surroundings
they are never
where they are they are in their
the stream of their thinking as you
become more aware of your sense
perceptions
your alertness and when i say alertness
don't let that be just a conceptual
thing alertness needs to be something
that you can only can only know what
alert awareness is by experiencing alert
awareness you cannot understand
conceptually what alert awareness is
and everybody here
i would say can
knows already and can verify in their
own experience
the difference between
being absorbed in your the inner being
identified with the voice in your head
which is habitual compulsive thinking
and
being in a state of alert awareness our
repeated experiences shape our brain
does this remind you of anything right
it's exactly what this monk told me
what we practice becomes stronger
everything that we practice every single
moment matters these are brains from
harvard i think that makes them a little
more special
and basically sarah lazar did this
wonderful early research and what she
found is that
meditators the actual parts of their
brain that have to do with attention
concentration emotional intelligence
compassion those parts of the brain
actually get stronger bigger it's what
it's called cortical thickening
and that this thickening is correlated
with practice
what we practice gets stronger
so the way i like to think of it is we
have these super highways of habits
and they're just like they're
well-grooved pathways in our brain right
they just
you know they're what we automatically
do
and what mindfulness is helping us start
to do is to kind of like
build kind of like i think of it as like
digging a country road you're you're
clearing all the brambles in your brain
you're creating this new neural pathway
that's like oh i'm gonna actually do it
with compassion this time or with a
little more patience or a little more
presence and so instead of going down
that same super highway of habit
we're shifting and we're going down a
different pathway
and every single time that we do this
we're strengthening that pathway so that
eventually that pathway becomes the
habit detachment from any feeling
emotion or even sometimes expectation
to the day it's not feeling anything and
allowing yourself to feel things even
when they're good you know a lot of
people have done so much work in their
life to blot out negative emotion that
they're not letting in positive emotion
or so many people feel like they've been
failing so much in their lives they
don't have a connection to the things
when they do succeed so they're not
integrating success
right they might have a good thing a
good series of things happens to them
but they don't feel them they don't
allow themselves to take that success in
that that win in it and really
internalize and say wow you know i did
that
and since that moment of satisfaction or
pride to doing something amazing they
never allow themselves any of the
positive emotions of life and they don't
allow those imposing emotions to stick
to settle in that's why one of the first
things that a psychologist will do in
working with a new patient is make sure
at the end of the day they start
journaling positive things that happen
throughout their day it's been
scientifically proven that you can
essentially just start a gratitude
journal and lift up your level of
happiness in life why because now you're
paying attention for the things that do
bring you positive emotion and happiness
in life you're recording them you're
writing them down it's physicalizing
that memory and feeling it and sensing
it and allowing it to come in
so try that
you know if you feel like you've been
detached from emotion in life it's time
to allow that back in to allow yourself
to feel passionate and excited about
things again to allow yourself to get
dorked out about a new learning
opportunity a new thing you're going to
see to allow yourself to say you know
what i did that good for me to have a
sense of pride about some things you
know you deserve that you did some good
things and it's also allowing yourself
not to be detached from negative things
you know so many people are so scared to
experience a negative thing that
it's like they've never developed any
strength or capability of dealing with
those things right do you know anybody
who can't handle conflict they're always
running from conflict because they've
always detached from that emotion oh i'm
scared i'm scared
part of the way that we become mature
and enlightened adults is we start to
face the things that we are fearful of
or we are scared of and we allow
ourselves to feel it and to sense it
it's okay to feel the fear it's okay to
feel uncomfortable about something it's
okay to feel vulnerable it's okay to
feel what other people might call
negative or scary or uncertain emotions
because the more comfort that you start
to have with uncomfortable emotions the
more comfort you have with uncomfortable
situations the more you start to develop
more consciousness about how to deal
with them right and the only way you're
going to develop comfort with them is
allowing yourself to accept that and to
acknowledge wow this is the feeling i'm
having right now about this why am i
feeling this way is this how i want to
feel will this add or contribute here is
there anything i can do to shift or
generate a new emotion that would be
more positive or healthy for me that's
consciousness
so you have to be you don't have to you
can't do that if you're detached from
every emotion or every opportunity and
every experience that comes into your
life you have to feel again every time
we have a thought we make a chemical and
and if you have
uh an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones
based in survival
those are the thoughts that begin to
push the genetic buttons that create
disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems and those problems
are memories that are etched in the
brain that are connected to certain
people certain objects certain things at
certain times and places so if you
believe that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny the
moment you think about your problems
you're thinking in the past right
now every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear so the moment
we feel those emotions it takes a
thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion
a stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition
so if the environment signals the gene
and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is
the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
then we're thinking in the past right
and so we call that
the familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh i got to see this person i got to go
to that meeting i hate doing this and
now they get in their routine
and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person
running through the same routine every
single day is on autopilot and their
body's now dragging them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
and the bodies saying you're out of
schedule you normally at 8 in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind
wants to return back to its familiar
territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling
okay i'll complain just so i can feel
suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
and step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious of those unconscious thoughts
becomes aware of how they speak and how
they act and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm gonna feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not to live in
the familiar future familiar past or
predictable future you're not going to
think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person wants to just get angry while
they're sitting there there's an arousal
and they notice the body is amping up
and revving up and they settle it back
down now they're telling the body it's
no longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
of that emotion the more they lower the
volume that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're gonna
take their power back there's gonna be a
break in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else mindfulness is a
translation of a pali term and pali was
the vernacular language in which the
teachings of the historical buddha were
first written down
and the word in pali is saki
and it connotes awareness attention
and remembering and the awareness and
attention part are pretty much the way
we use them in english to be aware and
to pay attention but the remembering is
different it's not about remembering
what you had for breakfast or for that
matter even remembering childhood trauma
it's about remembering to be aware and
pay attention at each moment of our day
now there's a um a scholar of the
ancient text named john dunn at emory
university
and he raised the following criticism he
said you know
if you could imagine a sniper
poised on top of a building getting
ready to take out an innocent victim
that sniper would be very aware
very attentive and every time his mind
wandered from the task at hand he'd be
zeroing right in on it and john said i
don't think that's exactly the attitude
you're trying to develop in yourselves
as a psychotherapist nor the attitude
you're trying to cultivate in your
patients or clients something's missing
here
and what's missing
is a sense of non-judgment acceptance
kindness and friendliness now there are
some scholars who say that's included in
sati but the important point is that
this non-judgment or acceptance is a
skill unto itself and which takes some
work to cultivate let me show you what i
mean
join me in looking at this fellow
and just take in the picture of him
and see what emotion arises as you look
at him
and raise your hand if what you feel is
a sense of harsh and critical judgment
[Music]
we can talk afterwards if so but you
know most of us look at him and feel
something like oh
right okay now even if he pees and poops
at the wrong time in the wrong place
even if he doesn't listen to
instructions we can understand he's
young he's a puppy he needs training
right
now when you take out mindfulness
practices most of us one of the first
things we see is that our mind does
actually pee and poop at the wrong time
in the wrong place and it doesn't listen
to instructions at all that is quite
quite unruly and the same kind of loving
attitude that we would cultivate toward
that puppy that's what we're going to
try to cultivate toward whatever arises
in our consciousness including
depressive feelings anxious feelings
physical pain and the like there's a
well-known zen teaching story
about a horrible sadistic general
who had come to town this was in
medieval japan
and they were
burning crops and burning buildings and
killing the able-bodied boys and men and
they were raping women it was horrible
and this general really wanted to
vanquish the town's folks and he caught
wind that they respected their zen
master so he took his horse and he rode
up the hillside into the main hall of
the zen temple and they're sitting on
the meditation cushion as this little
old man the zen master
and the general takes his bloody sword
and he holds it over the zen master he
says don't you realize i can run you
through with the sword without blinking
an eye
and little old man looks up and he says
yes and i sir can be run through with a
sword without blinking an eye
and it said that at that moment the
general becomes disoriented and leaves
town
now it's not always going to work as a
military intervention but it speaks to
how these practices develop our capacity
to be with discomfort and not to have to
escape it once we've practiced
mindfulness for a while and spent time
dropping out of the thought stream and
staying at the sensory level let's say
the anger comes up and all i experience
is the body tensing up heart rate
increasing respiration increasing blood
pressure well you don't feel blood
pressure but body temperature increasing
and perhaps the thought
right coming in passing like a cloud in
the sky perhaps the image of
decapitating my former friend dancing
through the minds of high but it's all
seen as a kind of impersonal process of
mental contents arising and passing and
when we can experience it that way
we get much less caught in it and it is
much easier to let it come and go people
talk about being present being in the
moment being in the now and you see all
these cute little instagram quotes
floating around be in the moment be in
the now no one tells you how the hell to
do it
right you can't be in the moment if you
can't concentrate
the ability to be present
stems from being able to be concentrated
and put your awareness on something or
someone
for a certain period of time exactly
yeah so how can i be in the moment here
with you if i can't concentrate so
everybody talks about the end product
which is be in the moment be present be
mindful mindfulness right being sold
like
you know bottled water everywhere
but they don't teach you concentration
you can't be mindful unless you
concentrate
mindfulness is a byproduct of
concentration in understanding the mind
the simple way i teach people this is
there's two things you need to
understand you need to understand is the
mind and there's awareness so let's
define both of them i define the mind as
a vast space with many different areas
within it one area of the mind is anger
one air is jealousy one there is
happiness food sex photography so many
different areas of the mind and then you
have awareness i define awareness as a
glowing ball of light so imagine an orb
or a ball of light that can float around
so
your mind doesn't move but it's your
awareness that travels to different
areas of the mind so you hear people say
all the time i have a monkey mind or my
mind travels a lot my mind's all over
the place technically i believe from my
experience that's false the mind doesn't
move but it's awareness that's traveling
within the mind so your awareness can go
to the happy area of the mind it can go
to the sad area of the mind it can go to
the scientific area of the mind your
goal is to control your awareness that
ball of light and determine where it
goes in your mic
and your ability to keep that awareness
in one area of the mind for an extended
period of time
is your ability to concentrate so if
you're reflecting on something you're
meditating on something it's your
awareness it's in one area of the mind
and you're holding it there long enough
to actually gain knowledge from it i
know you talk about reading just now
right someone opens a book is reading
their ability to keep their awareness on
that page
the ball of light on that page right
allows them to gain information
from the book but if they can't keep it
there long enough
they don't gain anything
right so understanding awareness and the
mind is the precursor to learning how to
concentrate the simplest thing you can
do is practice doing one thing at a time
which is very difficult for people
so if you're speaking with someone give
that person your undivided attention
keep your awareness on them so imagine
your awareness again as a ball of light
i'm speaking to jim my awareness not
stripped away i bring it back it drips
away i bring it back so i use gym as an
opportunity to practice concentrating so
if you have a spouse or partner or loved
one that you see every day or you speak
to every day
then use that person as an opportunity
to practice concentration every time you
speak with your spouse could be two
hours throughout the day
give your spouse your undivided
attention now you have two hours of
practice then concentration this is a
quote from william james he said the
faculty of voluntarily bringing back
a wandering attention over and over
again
is the very root of judgment
character
and will
an education which should improve this
faculty would be the
education
par excellence
and then he went on to say but it is
easier to define this ideal than to give
practical directions for bringing it
about
i think if william james had
more
intimate familiarity with the
contemplative traditions he would have
instantaneously seen
that these were methods that can be used
to educate attention
a recent study published in a major
scientific journal used smartphones to
sample people's experience in the world
and they asked people several questions
they asked them what are you doing right
now
and i had to check off on a list of
activities and the second question is
where is your mind right now
is it focused on what you're doing or is
it focused elsewhere and the third
question that they ask them is how happy
are you or unhappy are you right at this
moment
and what was found in this study this
was a sample of thousands of people what
was found is that the average
american adult
spends 47 percent of her or his waking
life not paying attention to what
they're doing
folks we could do better
even if it's just a smidgen better
we could do better
and when they were not paying attention
to what they're doing
they reported that they were unhappy
so let me end
with just telling a little story
i was in dharmsala with his holiness the
dalai lama
on one occasion and
during a tea break
i was with him with just one other
person so just the three of us and there
was this the person who was with me was
this really crazy japanese scientist
um
and the japanese scientist leans over
and he said to his holiness your
holiness can you please tell us the time
in your life when you are the most happy
and i thought that was real that's a
really interesting question and
just like that his holiness said right
now speaking of learning from lessons
you've been around a lot of incredible
entrepreneurs and i know you did a
reality show with richard branson says
10 12 years ago you said yes
what was that like and what's been a big
lesson you've learned from him and what
was the show and
what'd you learn yeah the show was
called the rebel billionaire and it was
the apprentice version richard branson's
version of that they were looking for 16
entrepreneurs so i'm like hey i'm an
entrepreneur i want to do this and i
really wanted to meet richard i sort of
had set intentions out there that i was
going to manifest him becoming a friend
in my life so when i heard about the
show i was like oh this is interesting
this might be how this happens so i
applied for it and um
uh it was wild so it's how big how big
was spanx at the time was it really well
known was it like just kind of it was
pretty i mean it was four years in it
was doing great yeah multiple seven
figures yeah my lawyers begged me not to
do it they're like what are you doing
you own this company you're gonna do a
reality show i was like i just want to
know richard i just feel like this is a
chance so um
so
yeah and all the business challenges
took place around the world in different
cities and instead of if you didn't win
the business challenge going into a
board room to get fired you had to do a
crazy stunt like a world record breaking
stunt because richard is obviously
like a huge adrenaline junkie guy so um
in addition to being an amazing
entrepreneur and the very first day of
filming i had to climb the side of a hot
air balloon at 9000 feet in the air on a
dangling rope ladder and have tea climb
to the top and have tea on top of the
balloon with richard that's insane it's
insane so what did you guys talk about
on the top oh my god i talked about like
how do we get down and that's what he
said you climb back down i was like what
i didn't think about that it was so
scary yeah oh my gosh yeah so it took me
48 minutes to climb to the top it's at
the height of a 17-story building and
the dangling rope ladder was just like
hanging out into the abyss of
nothingness wasn't anchored to anything
so i'm like climbing it
and um there's cameras that was the
first day of filming so two months later
i know i like cameras up there
yes
helicopters circling
probably probably
i had to do all these crazy stunts the
next stop i had to do is i had to jump
off the side of the victoria falls gorge
in africa
on a with a bungee cord attached to me
and
my
guy on my team was dangling on a wire on
a crane
10 feet out from the cliff and each
person had to come up and stand there
and you couldn't run and jump and you
had to stand still and jump and if he
caught you you were okay and they'd put
you back on the cliff and if not you
fell 385 feet
on a bungee cord
and so i am beyond terrified of heights
it's like one of my i'm so afraid of
heights i cry on airplanes still during
takeoff a lot of times
and
i was one of the only people to make the
jump richard didn't make the jump all
these other guys that were like amazing
athletes didn't make the jump and i like
to talk about this because i always talk
about aiming high and the importance of
aiming high in life and then i think all
of us we don't aim high enough
and so watch where you're aiming and
that that's saying you know if you shoot
for the moon if you miss you're at least
with the stars and afterwards everyone's
like sarah how did you make that jump
you're literally like the only
contestant look at you i said well i was
aimed at the pulley six feet above his
head where were you aiming and i aimed i
didn't even look at him i aimed six feet
above his head and i landed at his waist
and he caught me and everybody else was
aiming at his face and landed at his
feet and missed
amazing so it's like a really just
poignant
example of the importance of aiming high
first enemy we all have
is doubt
you know we we doubt whether or not
we're capable we doubt whether or not
we're worthy we doubt whether or not
we'll succeed we doubt whether or not we
even deserve it and it's so unfortunate
because i think doubt is one of the
greatest enemies of our lives and it's
so easy to overcome but most people
won't practice the discipline of
overcoming it which is weird right they
say oh i'm so doubtful and they stop
and it's like if you have any negative
recurring emotion in your life doesn't
maturity require you to face it and say
hey how do i fix this you know if you're
always doubtful you can't just wander
around saying i'm so doubtful like some
kind of victim that's not fair to the
humanity you've been given that that
real power of free will that says hey
you can direct your consciousness that's
why you have this big prefrontal cortex
other animals can't we can so handle it
if you've been plagued with doubt your
whole life then face it stop running
from it i know that sounds hard to say
to people but i was i had the same story
i was so doubtful that people would want
care about what i say i was so doubtful
that people would want to read my books
or listen to me at all i was so doubtful
that i could chase my own dreams and i
realized
for what reason am i doubtful
because of past failures in this space
no i'm trying something new because
people told me i might not be able to do
it so what makes them an expert on my
capabilities and my potentialities i
thought well why am i so doubtful we're
doubtful because the the germ of fear
spread in our body because somebody
planted it there one time or we
cultivate it with our own thoughts
and at some point maturity and
consciousness says if doubt has been
plaguing you let's have a look at it and
let's realize well how do you banish it
well every single thing that we know
from spirituality from philosophy from
the great writers and the great texts of
human culture has all revealed one thing
where there is doubt
grant me faith
that we have to have faith and faith
does not mean the absence of doubt
matter of fact the very definition of
faith we lies that doubt is still there
right you can't have faith unless
there's some part of you that says well
i'm going to go anyway despite the doubt
so i'm not saying we have to get rid of
doubt forever and handle it i'm saying
doubt should never prevent you from
advancing when you feel like advancing
that in your own mind you must say okay
i must trust in my abilities i must
trust that i will figure it out i must
trust that i can build it i must trust
that i can get some help and
progress
even though the doubt might be there
look the hero is a hero because the hero
does it anyway right even though the
hero's terrified and risking it all goes
anyway and we're all heroes in some way
we can all be courageous but i also
think you know what society overblows
courage society says you know courage
has to be some big magnificent act but
it's not i mean courage in this world
anymore is just having the the belief in
yourself and having the
the ability to genuinely express who you
are
if you're doubting yourself
the only way through is to give yourself
more faith
and take more action and with more faith
and more action comes more competence
with more competence comes more
confidence in psychology they call it
the competence confidence loop right the
more you learn and try the more you
master and develop so go out there even
with that yes let the doubt be there but
do it anyway started the agency with 45
people that didn't work in the industry
i knew nothing about the industry i read
nothing about the industry so i started
vaynermedia i built a creative shop that
i put media in the name
i had both media and creative under one
roof and had no idea that it was unique
so we were doing all these unusual
things
what it led to
is
a very large agency that has
not played by the industry rules but has
driven business results for its clients
so now we do have
900 people globally we do have the us la
and new york offices and
london and opening up singapore and
very frankly feel very confident we're
about to get a big scope for the world
cup in qatar and that means middle east
and looking at
you know
south america so i i think it's going to
be interesting to see what happens i
think
because of some of the awards we're
winning this week just i'm feeling from
the creative class here a little bit of
more of a
okay you can be in the club and i'm
laughing i'm like i don't want to be in
the club
i don't mind to be in the club
but there's only one club i want to be
in which is
wouldn't you want to be a creative that
in real life when you hang out with your
friends people know what you're talking
about
like how many more times do people here
want to spend 20 years of their life
making tvc that when they talk about it
and they're like you know the ibm spot
and their friends and relatives like i
have no idea what you're talking about
and if they do it's because they tried
really hard to find it
right um
i think that
people want to i think if you're
creative i think you want it to be seen
i just don't know what else to say and i
think you know what mike and adam will
tell you if you decide to yap with them
after this is after having careers in
fancy places doing fancy stuff it's fun
to make
it you know think about all the ideas
that you guys have had that will never
see the day of life
like you guys are all 12 years away six
years away
four years away from being the final
decision maker to actually see something
made right now you're politicking
and and strategizing on how to convince
the two people above you to actually
make the thing you believe it
you're not in the creative industry
you're in the internal politicking
industry
that's why volume will set this industry
free
we have interns from day one
in ad school
being able to see their thoughts in
market from the biggest brands in the
world
literally in terms of we have literally
interns already in our company that have
had more pieces of content seen by
humans than some of the people here
that's real
that's going to play out i hope for all
of you
i want you to be in a place where you
get to be creative for real instead of
working at a bank
and uh
fighting for
a half pregnant version of your idea to
see the world
and that's why so many of you have to do
things on the side
because you can't scratch your itch you
are one decision away from changing your
life
and you have to accept that your one new
meeting one new relationship one new
contact one new action
one new decision
away from shifting your life from where
it is right now to a totally different
place so what's the decision you already
know i could go backstage now there's
something you've been hesitating on
there's a contact you need to make isn't
there there's a job you need to quit
there's a relationship you need to
engage in maybe there's a relationship
you need to leave i don't know what it
is but i know there's a decision that
you need to make to take you to the next
level just like i know that's true for
me because decisions shape our destiny
when they're backed up by some massive
ass action
okay but you can't take the action if
you don't decide everyone say yes people
avoid being desperate think of the fact
they come here tonight and they're down
they're not where they want to be
financially their relationships aren't
what they want maybe they're in a
desperate place and you might think
that's a negative thing but when you're
in a desperate place you take the best
actions desperation is a great place to
be those of you that are achieving one
of the reasons the achievement has
slowed down is you've allowed yourself
to feel less desperate
when you were broke and starting your
business or when you were brand new in
your relationship and you were desperate
to get her to love you or desperate to
get him to love you you took massive big
action how many of you are moms in the
room raise your hand you mobs if you
woke up tomorrow morning and your baby
wasn't in their bed
would you be desperate right away yes or
no
big time desperation you wouldn't be
thinking about what you need to do you'd
be acting wouldn't you you'd immediately
make the decision you take massive
action you searched the house you'd go
into the street would you worry if your
makeup was on right how you looked what
people thought about you
you wouldn't would you have to have the
perfect plan to go find your baby that's
missing you wouldn't need any of that
because you were desperate
so when you remove desperation all this
[ __ ] creeps into your life where you
think you have to have the perfect plan
and look the perfect way and have the
perfect thoughts and be all zen and
perfect what you need is to be desperate
what you need is to get after it and i
want you to get desperate to make that
decision why because our obsessions
become our possessions
which you obsess about most regularly
you will eventually possess in your life
the challenge for most people sisters
and brothers is that we obsess on the
things we're fearful of what we don't
have what we're worried about and then
we end up possessing those things over
and over again rather than programming
ourselves to become obsessed with what
we want what our dreams are what we
believe we deserve when we become
obsessed about those things long term we
end up possessing those things can i get
an amen for that yes
yeah most of us don't replace the
external parts of our lives because
those things happen
naturally without thought the external
results of our life in order to replace
ourselves with the next best version
requires intention requires obsession
requires desperation everyone with me on
that say yes
so it's not unnatural to change
your friends that think you're crazy to
have started your business or come to a
seminar spend money you don't have
they're the crazy ones
it's unnatural to be the same person you
are right now next year for all of you
in here the 35 year old you should be
gone next year forever and there should
be a brand new better 36 year old
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want these seven steps to start building
wealth for yourself check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there you know for seven days track
your latte factor oprah when i did the
one of the oprah shows she we showed the
lattice factor and she pulled off a
cloth and showed this woman's latte
factory and we had a quarter of a
million dollars in cash